Now don't worry. This is not your computer misbehavior. How many times have
you see often windows like what I'm showing you on this screen? Why does this
happen? The simple answer, programs are not
being hygienic, that is, they are not
cleaning up after themselves. Now, you can
not fault the applications themselves. If an application
encounters an error or the user decides to
kill an application, either ways, the system services
that the application was using have to have
a way of gracefully terminating and getting rid
of the state, that is the bread crumbs it created along the way. And it may
have strewn such breadcrumbs all over the computer.
Some may be in data structures in memory,
some may be visible, like the orphan windows that I'm showing you on the screen,
and so on. Bottom line is these breadcrumbs are using
up precious resources in the computer. It may be visible resources like real
estate, on your display of failed
applications or invisible resources like memory leaks,
network bandwidth that is being chewed up
by connections that are persisting beyod the life
of an application. Persistent data structures on
the disk and so on. LRVN and [UNKNOWN]
which is really and implementation of the
RVN semantics on top of a persistent file
cache, took a very narrow view of
recoverability, namely recovering the state that need to
be persistent across system crashes. Either becaue
of software failure or power failure. But
imagine a system service that spans several
machines and network file server is a
good example. NFS is suppoed to be
stateless which means that the client-server interaction
maintains no state at the server, pertaining to the clients. So what that means
is, taking down a file server and bringing
up The file server again does not need any
coordination with the clients that this file server
may be serving at any point of time. But
look at what is happening from the point
of view of the system, especially the client boxes
that are interacting with the file system. In
this case, there are clients all over the network
so far as this file server is concerned.
And indirectly, and if a server is leaving breadcrumbs
all over the LAN because of accesses that
a client may have made with a file server,
in each one of these boxes. Imagine what
happens when a client program that initiated a file
system call quits in the middle of its
exchange with the file server? How will the file
server know how to clean up all the mess?
And in fact, with a stateless file server, doesn't even
know that there have been breadcrumbs created on this
node. The short answer is, the file system cannot know
about these kinds of breadcrumbs that have been created
all over the network. And I'm giving you a file
server as one example, but in general, all of
the system services that a client program is reliant on
create state, and this partial states may live
forever if an application crashes in the middle.
Worse yet, you as a user may be
asked by the operating system to do some cleanup,
not knowing what the cleanup may entail for
you, personally. Am I going to lose two hours
of work that I just completed? I have no idea what will happen when I click the
"OK" button here.